okay hello
I like to start off with a question
how many here in this room have never
ever seen this program before
please raise your hand
one oh that's cool okay then I will ask
a second question how many people here
in this room has never used this program
before in the gauge for that
no one
oh that's cool that's great but I hope
at least I will I will be able to learn
some of you some new tricks about this
so for the obvious
this is called Ms paint
and did you know that Ms paint was first
released in the first version of Windows
in Windows one back in 1985 it's
actually older than me and probably many
of you as well
paint and notepad is is only two
applications that still exist in the
current version of Windows today and
this makes paint one of the most
available programs of all times
and this is also probably the reason why
so many of you or all of you have
touched this at some time even though
it's been a long time since last time
um I think it was in 2017-ish when
Microsoft released windows 10.
they then said that no we are not going
to include paint anymore
and what happened then it was it was
that the paint Community whoever they
are
um
they get mad and long story short
Microsoft came back and like okay okay
we're gonna we're gonna keep paint okay
that's fine
um so instead of removing paint they
gave it a kind of a makeover so now in
Windows 10 it looks something like this
and windows 11 which I haven't upgraded
to yet it looks like something like this
so
today I will show it in this version
every feature will be available in in
both versions so you know
um yeah back in the days back in early
1990s late 1980s
um Microsoft used paint as a showcase
product
they said like look here
look we have a paint tool that you can
draw in it looks awesome great yay but
now you know there are so many other
applications that is so much better so
paint kind of lost it Glory Days right
but hey I'm here to show you some of the
hidden features so maybe you can use
paint a little bit more
okay so sorry I forgot to present myself
in the beginning my name is Marianne
melus I work at the company in dubstep
in Oslo and I'm I'm a software developer
I'm not the designer as you can see
and I like to use paint and I've used it
for many many years even though
even since I was a small kid and fooled
around my parents computer and since
then I've been figuring figuring out
some of its hidden Futures which I like
to share with you guys
so shall we just start right
so let's see if I can get this working
let's see
this is working
once again
not moving
I need this to work
try to just
minutes ago
sorry about that
um okay then we'll just go for Plan B
then I will use my touchpad
Okay so
I use paint for for drawing
um sketches for my clients and let's say
I have this blue button here this info
button here
and you probably for some of you guys
that have used this it's uh
um experience this that you get the
white background with you right it's
kind of annoying
this feature is not that advanced and
not that
uh hidden but I like to include it
anyway
sewing paint you have something called
transparent transparent selection
if you select this one you're able to
avoid to picking up the the white
background with you
so then you just place
the button over here
many of you probably knew that already
so let's take it a step further
um so let's say I want to bring the the
blue button button out again of this
gray panel if I do this like this I will
bring the gray panel in the gray
background with me right not ideal
so in order to fix that problem
um you have to know about a certain
trick
you see those two colors up here color
one and color two
color two is associated with your
background color
so if you select the color 2 as the
why doesn't this work
um
then you are able to bring it out again
so let's see
I use this Color Picker tool in order to
select for color two I have to right
click or double tap
with my touchpad if I select just single
or left click I select this as my color
one
but right now I just want it for color
too so if I select the blue button again
I'm able to drag it out
so yeah this is one of the feature I use
the most when I make sketches for my
clients
but let's take a look another another
one
okay so this is a flower
um
and let's say I want to remove only one
single color
let's say I want to remove the um the
light green color each year
but not the dark green
in order to do that I have to select the
color I like to remove
select the rubber tool and then right
click or double tap with my mouse oops
it's so much easier when you have a
mouse
come on
now
why is this not working
doesn't work the touchpad is not
it's not working for me but yeah if you
right click with your rubber then you're
able to only remove one color
just give me a minute I will just try to
fix this because I want to show you
why is this not connect there
I'm sorry guys I know I take a lot of
time to doing this
no no okay it says it's Perry though
but okay anyway
um if I want to change the color for for
the green one if I want to select just
one color and and change the color
I can use also the same method so then I
select the color I want to change it to
from that color and then I can
if I click doesn't work on my
I know it's bad oh now it worked okay so
then again able to color just one
one color
only the green one
sorry about that
um when I
um
when I use paint I like to be a little
bit more efficient while doing so
um one of the future is
um you know the magnifying glass you can
zoom in and out you can you can do that
with also using your wheeler on your
mouse to scroll in and out my mouse
doesn't work right now so but you can
also hold in the
um
uh you can also click for zoom in and
right click to zoom out which is more
efficient than than dragging this this
thing down here I think
um as a developer I use copy pasting a
lot I use Ctrl C Ctrl V multiple times
during the day but in paint there's
actually another more efficient way to
copy paste this stuff
so
um
let's say I want to copy this info
button you can do the Ctrl C Ctrl V then
you get in the corner
that's not most efficient way so in
order to copy paste this thing hold down
the control button and then you're able
to drag
the button multiple times around and
then you are able to
to make multiple copies of it
if you ever want to
um resize anything there's a resize
option here you can double it in size or
Minify it
make it smaller Etc
you can also rotate
um both in different degrees and also
vertically and horizontally
and Etc which I use a lot
um
say
um yeah and one more thing
um almost forgot did you know that in
paint you can make custom brushes you
probably used other tools and have tried
different custom brushes you can do that
here too let's say I make a custom Birch
a star for example
uh and then I select my custom brush or
select my star and if I hold the shift
button I'm able to make
a custom brush out of it
you probably don't see the use case here
right
but yeah I use it actually when I'm
having a button and I want to make it
longer
so if I select the end of the button I
want to make it longer I hold the shift
button and then just drag the button out
I'm a little bit nervous so
so it's not getting straight but yeah
you get the point right
so yeah
[Music]
um
I don't know how much time I have left
but for those who were
um
some saw this in the beginning you can
see that this isn't actually a web app
on JS app
jspain.app it's available as long as
your Wi-Fi so for you guys who are not
Windows user you can actually do paint
and you probably maybe think some of the
features were not available back then
but they are actually are so you can
let's see
uh I just had switch
you have the transparent background over
here it's a little bit hidden but yeah
you have the same same stuff here so
so now you all can use paint if you like
to
Okay so
I think that's that's what I have to
show you guys but if you want to know
more features please contact me I will
be standing here afterwards and by the
website in the arena and I hope you guys
learned something new today and maybe
you can use paint more in your daily
daily work that's what I do
um so yeah thank you so much for
listening and hope you have a great day
[Applause]